got it or how you want me how you want
to handle uh I only picked this topic so
we can jab little Jabs at solve all
right but what happened to Xbox taxic
game awards what happened no we we still
do that we'll still do that okay okay
yeah we'll still do that all right so um
and that's when I give away the next
game because we got a game give away
yeah so we do the Persona I'll I'll set
it up so um yeah Persona 6 s could be
breaking a 30-year tradition uh it
released as a multiplatform game
signaling a departure the series
long-standing launch exclusivity to
PlayStation sega's response during
investor report suggest that releasing
Persona 6 on multiple platforms
simultaneously could lead to increased
sales and potentially reach the
Milestone of selling 5 million copies in
the first year Atlas has been expanding
its relationship with Xbox and Nintendo
making it likely that Persona 6 will be
available on multiple platforms upon
release although an official
confirmation is still pending so they
actually spoke to um the rep in this
call and they just said yeah we believe
that it would be possible for a major
Persona title such as a numbered release
to sell 5 million copies in its first
year by releasing it on multiple
platforms and simultaneously worldwide
from day one and uh I believe I'm trying
to get uh that is indicated by sees
Haruki atami and I cannot pronounce this
koichi fukasawa that's the best I would
try so um this was during a quarterly
investor report so that was the first
bit of new news um second bit of news
obviously his addict been playing
Persona tactica and thoughts on that so
I guess we'll talk about that and then
we'll get into Mar RPG and some other
stuff but let's start off with the first
two bits of news this is your topic
addict yeah so you know I kind of I kind
of knew that this would happen as long
as PlayStation didn't secure it years
ago like after Persona 5 what I was told
is it was like that aren't normally made
years in advance usually made closer
towards the uh the game being finished
development unless it's like certain
things like they're funding the entirety
of the game like if Sony was funding
Persona 6 then most likely you wouldn't
see that but especially with this you
know relationship that Microsoft has
established with Sega it I kind of
figured this would happen as long as
PlayStation didn't lock it down uh years
ago and it's looking like that happened
I mean look what's crazy is like it
Persona 6 comes out if if Xbox is able
to secure that game pass day and date
like they've got with all the Persona
games and all the yakas of games like
you know how big that would be because
to me
Microsoft they're never going to truly
get into that area unless they have
stuff that's only on their platform uh
the the next best thing is to have Game
Pass games like like something like you
know Persona 6 and obviously when it
comes to something like that are they
going to get Persona 6 in game pass
probably not but it would be a really
good look if they did that you know
apparently finally M Walker is making
something that's not a mobile game so
it's like what what are they doing with
that and you know I see I see a lot of
movement I do I see you know it's just
like um you know can't I can't remember
which one of you said you know you look
at what's going on it was a patreon
question what's going on with it used to
be we didn't get no personas no yakas
yeah that's a fact and and these were a
lot of games every year that came out
especially how consistent they can get
these games out so it's just like look
when you look at these and you look at
the the landscape of things don't be
surprised when you see Persona 6p
popping up on that platform don't be
surprised and you know is it going to
sells better than like the switch of
PlayStation obviously not but who would
be acted like three people buy it on the
Xbox that's not the case like U but it'd
be interesting to see if they if they
get a a Game Pass back you know I I
would I would be
very like like amazed if they were able
to convince Sega like yo you know and if
there was something they were holding
off with for a bigger one it would be
Persona 6 all right fair enough start
with our esteemed guest Lord games Lee
um let's start just with the Persona
potential news of it being multiplat how
do you take that news that
information I'm going to be really
simple with it because I don't want to
take time time time m
um Square enx needs to take note and I
think they will show up I think they've
already I think they will take notes
they need to take not okay and you have
to teach the player bases that you will
show up on platforms you want to sell on
and that's that's the whole point if you
want to sell more copies and you want
those copies to be sold on xbo box where
previously they don't sell or whatever
like adct said they do sell but not to a
CT like millions and millions and
millions if you want to teach them to
buy your stuff you have to be there you
have to be Loy consistently it's not
just being there you have to be there
consistently you know you can't you
can't skip out on three sequels and they
expect me to buy a prequel like yeah
that's that's exactly that's my thought
that's exactly what you have to do you
have to teach your your fan bases uh
where you're going to be and you have to
stay there stay so so we got to groom
them
properly yes
wow moving on that's it that's that's my
thing fair enough Lord games the Lord
hustle hustle and motivate man just the
Persona news potential multiplatform at
launch what are your thoughts on these
rumors potentially that could happen uh
it's much needed um I'm surprised they
haven't done that a lot sooner but if
the demand on Xbox in particular if the
demand is there then you know throw
those games on there I think they um
because they re-released uh three four
and five the variance of three four and
five on a in Game Pass and maybe they
was just doing that just as like a quick
test to be like all right well let's see
how many people really want these and it
look like those numbers if this is true
this room is true it look like
everything hit the way that it should
have hit and if that's the case PA and
and the good thing also when so you
saying said Xbox hit it right pause oh
man the the good thing the good thing
husto is when you put when you put he
said godamn it
The Good the good thing hustle is when
you put like these games on game pass
and you give you know all these millions
of people that are subscribed to Game
Pass access to Persona five four and
eventually three you know when Persona 6
comes out there's a huge possibility
that you have you know got a lot more
sellers because you made the entry so
low to make it where anyone could walk
in that that you know put $15 $20 into
into the service for a couple months
now now they might actually buy your $
6070 game when they didn't even know
your franchise existed before
then fair enough Lord Sovereign my
brother just see do now now he's your
brother but he couldn't side with you in
the we we're over
that we're over we're dead anyway what
does it matter you know you know I
remember you know there's certain you
know are you going to been the knee now
or later you know on the line I was told
this
oh so we holding on okay I see no we
hold Lear I learn from the best you
learn from K you learn from King David
until until it's
official nowhere nowhere in this press
release did it say anything about
Xbox I mean I mean he did say multiple
platforms yeah aka the next Nintendo
platform in the PC
there this what we doing this what we
doing K I'm not like this this and I
will say this and I agree with hustle
100% all of y' frauds that talk about
they don't have Japanese games y'all
better play these games y' better have
played Royale when it was there y'all
better be playing tactica now and you
better play reload when it comes out
facts and because I I I do think this
obviously if they're making it already
they're making they're not g to start
making Xbox version now right whatever
if it's a done deal is it's done already
they're just not saying I I was told by
somebody in the know most triaa
developers can have a port for Xbox in
six
months really okay so maybe so maybe it
could
happen I just want to know how how I'm
receiving these needs yo yo he said
really to me I think his exact words was
six to n months so there was a little
wiggle room they putting it out early
before
so so let let's be clear about this also
about the the terms of this the terms if
it's one day later oh oh this what we
doing okay okay f it
was no we going go down hold up that
that was in the original fine just I
just want to clarify that clarify I I
take it I need these these I I want to
see Yo Sol imagine if if some bers gay
three energy happened here he wins then
he wins then he wins then he wins I'm
taking it all away they told I wait till
it's my turn but just what to
here we we messed up we messed up the
time zone stuff I'm sorry going be two
hours later okay this what we doing okay
Finish y finish no okay like I said in
the past he he learned from me he
learned from the best he learn from the
best you better watch out he going to go
on Playstation switch to New Zealand and
say I'm play
so uh but like I said in the past if if
this happens yes it needs to happen yes
um yeah it needs to happen man that
persona's gotten so big over the years
especially with five it it it got to
happen so um if it doesn't I I just I'm
G be honest I'm G Snicker and laugh if
there is some sort of PlayStation you
know because it's like really because it
goes to the point like why would Jim
when he was there not try to secure this
you you you know
howed you know how there's like a good
chance that I really feel like you
you're going to lose this because Atlas
announced our brand new IP on Xbox
stage and that when I saw that I was
like but it's not Persona when I saw
that when I saw that when I saw that I
pretty much thought to
my you can have you can have you can
have the reantaso whatever
weio
that's the side joint that's the side
joint that's the side joint okay okay
that's what we doing all right now this
is good this is good to hear uh holding
on I respect it as you should as you you
learn from the best Lord kid your
thoughts on the Persona series
potentially being
multiplat I already know that's going to
happen like oh boy those had a chance
feeling was out there in the Land of the
Rising Sun they like yo you see all the
gays running around gay pass hey little
Sega hey little Sega how
what's your name little Sega I'm
Pana oh that's so nice that you here
yeah and tactics we just launched inside
Game Pass we like you here oh okay so is
your big brother coming yeah he's going
to be born soon and he's going to be six
and he's coming here and we're going to
have so much fun did you say he's going
to be born soon be bor Bor soon he said
he's going to be bored soon and he sex
and he's going to be
six he's he's the he's the sixth one of
us and and he's going to show up and
he's going to love it ins start Game
Pass well what about Sony we really
don't like it there it's cold
it's we we like it we like it here where
it's warm and fun and everybody here
interacts for real they got money here
they keep the lights
on all right all right little Sega go
have fun it don't it'll be more of us we
heard square is coming too because they
couldn't keep the lights on over there
because Final Fantasy 16 lost almost two
billion for hanging out with those
guys twittern said what is this stranger
danger energy yeah very stranger danger
energy well well go along little Sega
have fun thank
you I keep it like but yeah you got to
walk the other direction yeah definitely
of direction for sure I mean shout out
to the uh the
quarterly calling the
cops what's the matter y'all don't like
little
Sega that's out of pocket hey little
Sega that's out of pocket jumping this
was fun news to come across and uh yeah
I guess I just remember I was told King
I was told so many things I was told
that the shout out to ACG was here
remotely look at the shine on his face
right
I sat here and I watched ACG and sof
jump me and tell me about how the Sega
deal was only about Cloud I said okay
cool cool F and then I wish I wish ACG
was here I wish ACG was here to oh
nothing about games y'all this is
strictly counting your chickens too
early oh I'm counting I'm popping
bottles
early this is happening y'all s how
extra are you going to be if he's wrong
still oh let him I I I'll take all the
stipulations he throws at me so so for
me I'm just sitting there I'm like okay
cool and we saw the all jokes time we
did see the relationship continue to
improve but the the strongest point that
s and his brother kaibu you too you too
I remember you and um they told me they
said no Cog because Atlas run operates
to its own beat they do their own thing
so then as we continue to see but at the
end of the day they're still owned by
Sega shout to the shout out to the queen
sarahan shout out to Phil Max you know
what Sarah heard you was like I got you
I just see those beautiful trips to
Japan and TGs and every year imagine
those conversations yeah I got this
podcast I listen to his name's Cognito
she did it for me she did it the queen
did it for me the queen did it shout out
shout out to Queen Mother
Sarah she did it for the tribe and uh
yeah I just see every year it just seems
to get a little bit better then you see
Persona 5 tactica new IP release you
know which we'll talk about and then
obviously the new IP that I forgot the
wild name that it has that it's coming I
thought that was big but look re
fantasio fantasio right but the he all
jokes out but the he investors talking
about yo this I they should rename it to
the beginning of the end for S to hear
them talking about how much money they
could sell they would to sell 5 million
this is giving off a lot of Square Enix
energy and to me it's like yo the real
the reality of this they cannot miss the
Xbox and the Nintendo platforms it it's
just too much money on the table and
these exclusive deals are not netting
the value that they once had and this is
historic cuz to Sol's point and I
understand why they standing on the
Square is because this is a relationship
almost nearly 30 years P Persona 1 was
what like 94 95 like it's been a long
time that these games have historically
had that relationship but I do think
it's about the money it's about the
business aspect and we will see so I'm
just going to I'm just going to be
patient just going to be patient and
wait for those kns sof doesn't lose off
the y'all so I have to save it this if
it does happen the way I anticipate it I
just can't wait so we will see when it
goes down part of me wish is I could
like take a time machine and just see
the reaction to both ways like but I
want I want Cog to win not because Cog
will win the bet but because I want
Persona 6 on Xbox so so ironically right
now our roads are in the same direction
oh yeah we're definitely allow to go
this one the new IP is metaphor and it's
metaphor colon fantas Fantasia whatever
but abolutely